I do eat chef oh my god that horrible we
don't look like that and Scotland hello
all our Babel a switch Capaldi here I'm
gonna watch to some of your clips and
try to guess what happens next
and these are my shocking answers and
things I've read my [ __ ] Brit Milah
my I said so I talked about AMA I'm
gonna make a conscious effort to not
talk about pubes and share all the time
but that's the brand new weird that
everyone loves bummed so much but that's
where the pure lives look as if it is
silly and as Shepherd but as with who
lives the food does loving the bomb
there's all rap songs about eating the
cake which eating the cake as eating a
bottom scrap scanning and asks do you
stand up and sit down when your wife in
your bar I know what I really wanted I
really want to explain it late and all
people say that you shouldn't stand up
because it congeals and it's like
peeling back like a like feel about like
I'd like a toast with chocolate with
Nutella but if anybody watching right I
know again I know this is maybe fun stop
[ __ ] setting down and wait on your
ass and [ __ ] add that should go
without saying dawn wait towards your
genital next question generate well yes
all yeah spit when I was over at my
friend's house yeah
remember that was one there's no bet too
far amazing I don't know what are these
things about I mean that's looks like a
big on let's tell you what it feels like
I've done about that head oh alright
okay we don't look like that and
Scotland they don't need that one little
more chili line
oh it's [ __ ] crazy as far Mahan's
krisily which incidentally is also a
half an hour plasma port back porch
supposed to be pink in the middle
it looks a bit faint they have just took
quite a big debate over I mean I'm
always good at all for the penis shaped
snacks
just for that I don't usually eat
anything because I'm too busy spewing up
so whatever I had the neighbor for this
usually I could start it and they I'll
probably get pizza of something and
because my mother's cooking
[ __ ] disgusts me actually watching
mum [ __ ] sort your show
okay so options are a the kid gives the
ghetto the finger curly what did CAD
start smacking his sister head hats her
SEF stuff to stop him stop her singing
she's been singing for quite some time
he's pissed off so I'm packing C but I'm
having it set up we shall see some
things I put what [ __ ] I put my belly
button my finger in my belly button and
I'll give it a sniff I said it is a very
good that's a very good gauge of leg how
bad do I smell I wish I'd never seen
moose Capaldi's faces voices ruined for
me now what was my reply to this tweet I
think it was like I understand it must
be so difficult to get a boner every
time you hear my songs I get this tweet
outlaw [ __ ] well I got a lot of
tweets about the way I look right
some people are nicer than others a lot
people say like as I see look like my
cloth petite smiley
that old guy who ate that pimp you know
that that I get that saying to me on on
a daily basis
I was at an Edinburgh every weekend and
a girl came up to me and said lesson and
I know what people see on a any stuff
but that's the thinking a really
good-looking yeah
what what are people saying Elaine leave
that [ __ ] bad just see you think I'm
a sell look they sell look vain when was
the last time you made sense
well canal I was definitely in the last
seven days
so the first freeze we've got here is
putting lipstick on a peg and that
immediately makes me think I mean you
should be putting lipsticks on pegs it
all should remains me of the seeing you
do not polish but you can't polish at
out which I think there's some approval
approval nod so back there so I think
that's correct which so I've just
answered the question with another idea
how do you see it without like a fart in
the HUD Akane you can't expect something
that's so bad and it's so horrible by
just by putting something nice on it
okay a futile attempt to make something
look better than as see what I said
there was exactly as a new idiom for you
and you can't make a peg look pretty
simple by putting lipstick on it I shall
think pegs are quite pretty
so I thought what have sex with the
pagans only no bestiality undercurrents
here so last day at the Great Scott
Awards I went to the bathroom as a vain
well how am i went to toilets I was I
mean I don't know the caps nose but I
was at the toilets having a poo
it gave just my PR and Scotland came up
and says Louis we need you downstairs
for a minute I said that very hastily
wiped my ass I got down and I had to go
straight up and do a speech say it's
something about to be honest I'm just
about worried that masks are still
kicked and shaved and it was I was
straight back to that bathroom if I was
in a wad winner so this is a man who
definitely looks like he's maybe a
hungover of camping here that here the
options a a lightning straight causes a
boy to scream be the tent is blown away
by the wind see a startled deer run
straight for the tent I'm going to say a
lightning strike causes them to scream
because it looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's how I was raped
okay he's a pork scratching and these
ones are of the nation's favorite master
pork it sounds a bit dusty oh my [ __ ]
god that horrible master pork it as a
bill chuffing vaster NIMS that sounds
for this is going to be a [ __ ] I toss
up for the shutters snap these are
assault cakes laughs I could hate both
of these things on every inside them
Wow [ __ ] thick cardboard they're the
state and it's dry as [ __ ]
I suppose less the porky one because
it's actually flavor I'll be a terrible
flavor you're not supposed to pick stuff
on or kicks the post thing got that
makes sense
I don't you get a lot of cuddles I don't
really approach people in bars either do
you like the police station yeah that's
captioners it's definitely about the
cold sore that's on my face I've got a
cold sore no but it's something about
still got a cold shot on my face but it
hasn't made its way to my genitals just
yet
herpes hanging about my left foot away
on the more sane emoji was just yet yeah
an eagle but rest assured stole no
saying of anything on my genitals at all
I haven't done the touch of anyone and
quite something quite well acquainted
with a slow gay but I am still no
genital herpes thank you very much have
you even seen or saved a nude photo I
have never sent an in full because it's
a [ __ ] war fully unimpressive
piece of work that I've got going on
limit no one's gonna look at that and go
that looks appetizing
I have definitely I have received nude
photos on occasion because s 2019 John
Hancock as I thought has it not saying
that would be what Raymond slang it
wouldn't be raining slight FS America
John Hancock
I don't know it has a lothario of sorts
no it's not as means your signature
named after John Hancock who st. his
signature and
overly flamboyant we in the US
Declaration of Independence I don't know
anything about right away everything it
but for me signature I can tell he was
up track everybody else just do a nice
little day and we've got a lot of names
to go on here John hike up saying [ __ ]
that [ __ ] next so he's dad's telling
him to trouble with the ball and here we
go other the kid volleyball and his
dad's testicles and an absolute classic
the kid floors a tantrum and schemes I
hate football
I'd be put a ball in [ __ ] I hope
that's not [ __ ] me [ __ ] a shape
video and the Cadmus understands what it
means trouble with the ball I mean I
want them it to tick attack okay his
dad's balls because they ought to seem
like why would you even send us an if
it's either of those are two things I'm
gonna be [ __ ] region is betting on the
ball see it's quite cute that's not how
you double your right well I understand
though it was a cute video I thought we
were doing funny things if you could
become the biggest down world that
fellow Scot Calvin Harris wouldn't even
sell another record would you do it
it doesn't have to sell another records
it's [ __ ] maple oak so yes loyal come
and I have never met it's definitely
that's big red bottom that's shocking
huh I'm not a man lying on the floor
thank you very much for having me honest
that let's forget it
hey hey he said lock this again just
like IT demanded it alrighty denied that
you protect your I don't know like
octopus night